c'est vrai que le stockage de l'eau
c'est du bon sens quand l'eau est là
elle tombe on la garde et on utilise
quand on en a besoin
philippe pinta président d'uni grain
pour vous le besoin d'investissements et
l'innovation
ça passe par calvillo mais je suis aussi
un agriculteur dans le département de
l'aisne est pris dans des producteurs de
blé en france j'aurais d'abord pour
répondre à votre question rebondir sur
les propos d'eric woerth dans son
introduction et woerth a dit d'activité
l'agriculture est une activité
économique à part entière faut déjà
qu'on se mette d'accord là dessus à
partir de là on peut aborder toutes les
autres est question mais ça c'est
fondamental
c'est l'activité économique à une
activité économique aux dégâts de la
valeur ajoutée et on fait du social et
ont fait de l'environnement
aujourd'hui on est dans la démarche
inverse comme ça qu'on le ressent parle
d'abord d'environnement très peu de
social et pas du tout d'économie
résultats par on voit le marasme dans
lequel et l'ensemble les cultures à ce
jour hormis peut-être la viticulture qui
tire un peu son épingle du jeu dans les
chiffres 2014 contre des comptes de
l'agriculture 2014 il ya deux ans un bon
il y avait deux secteurs qui étaient
dans le rouge 30 % des agriculteurs de
porc
ces producteurs de porcs étaient dans le
rouge avant cotisations sociales 30% des
céréaliers étaient dans le rouge à vos
cotisations sociales et en 2014 2015
tous les autres secteurs nous ont
rejoints dans dessous voilà non il
s'agit pas de pleurer inutilement sa
juste juste de remettre la situation
dans laquelle on est aujourd'hui qui
explique tous les mouvements qui peut y
avoir sur le terrain ça c'est majeur de
ces majeurs donc il faut reprendre la
main sur l'économie
et c'est à travers le revenu a été fort
bien disputer dans dans la table d'avant
l'agroécologie c'est pas la réponse
sinon ça se saurait on le réussit plutôt
exactement l'inversé
c'est exactement ce que je viens de dire
mais à l'envers c'est à dire
l'environnement social c'est donc c'est
pas là dessus
le taux passera le redressement de
l'agriculture française ça passera par
la recherche par l'innovation qui sont
des facteurs de croissance toujours dans
tous les secteurs
si vous faites de la recherche
d'innovation
et que vous pouvez la mettre en oeuvre
c'est un vrai moteur de croissance et je
leur ai donné là dessus de deux exemples
si je prends l'exemple des céréales la
france exporte la moitié de sa
production
alors on peut dire à l'export' plus rien
à j'irai quand même tous nos amis
des pays du maghreb
je vois qu'il ya suffisamment de
problèmes aujourd'hui c'est pas la peine
de les accentuer
on exporte la moitié mon voisin dit on
est les premiers au monde à exporter des
semences eu des semences on est dans les
cinq premiers au monde pour exporter la
france est un petit pays
donc c'est une chance extraordinaire on
a un projet parce qu'il faut avoir des
projets pour réussir pour faire
l'économie
les projets en 2030 on a des projets
pour 2050 et dans ces projets c'est
produire plus pour les raisons que j'ai
un explicite et produire mieux pour
réduire les impacts sur l'environnement
pour faire du qualitatif et caetera et
ça ne pourra passer que par la recherche
et l'innovation
c'est majeur de chez majeur donc ça je
voulais déjà mais prendre ce premier
exemple tu produire plus du produire
mieux à travers l'innovation
deuxième exemple dont les innovations ne
trouve un projet qui lui paraissait très
intéressant qui était la méthanisation
et notamment de l'utilisation
''l'affaire tagro'' mairie c'est
d'associer et les éleveurs le monde de
l'élevage et le monde
céréalier puisque il faut les deux pour
pouvoir faire tout seul il ya eu un
projet qui était 1000 méthaniseur en
sept ans mais nous faisons en ces temps
se fait 140 parents british par
département aujourd'hui on est à pas ce
nom n'est pas 140 par département pas en
france on est à 40 et on pense qu'avec
ce qui vient de sortir dans les
réglementations nouvelles on va tomber
invente donc au lieu de le faire en sept
ans il faudra 50 ans mon arrivée kamil
ça te dira rien or pour nous c'est une
vraie stratégie aussi dans la
compétitivité à travers ces nouveaux
outils d'innovation
parce que ça permet et on voit en
allemagne un certain nombre
d'exploitations qui vous si les mêmes
difficultés que nous de pouvoir s'en
sortir parce que opus de diversifier et
c'est donc ça pour nous c'est c'est
majeur de ces deux exemples que je
voulais montrer
la recherche d'innovation c'est vraiment
un facteur de croissance puis vous dire
il faut nous juger sur les résultats et
nous foute la paix sur les moyens
laissez-nous les moyens jeu chez nous
sur les résultats c'est vrai pour
l'agriculture mais c'est vrai pour tous
les secteurs jugés nous que sur les
résultats
laissez-nous faire ne nous tu n'es pas
continuellement la main c'est le message
qu'on essaie de faire passer pas la
défiance la confiance tout à l'heure
maud fontenoy aussi parler parce que les
recherches et innovations
derrière ça ce qui bloque un peu cette
principe de précaution retourne toi
alain fort bien parler c'est aujourd'hui
c'est un peu dévoyé ça se transforme en
une action et ça c'est qu'un travail
tiennent donc du coup on a les discours
mais on n'arrive plus à mettre les
choses à mai des choses enfin donc non
nous le message c'est liberté
d'entreprendre
faites nous confiance fait confiance
faites confiance ça n'empêche pas le
contrôler la confiance n'empêche pas le
contrôle fait confiance et puis surtout
ne laissez pas ne laissons pas la
recherche et l'innovation quitter ce
pays c'est une richesse extraordinaire
dont profite tous les secteurs et les
notes bien entendu viens de vous le
démontrer c'est majeur de ces majeurs il
faut qu'on retrouve notre place mondiale
qu'à l'agriculture et l'agroalimentaire
rien que les céréales sont entre 8 et 10
milliards de balance commerciale
positive par an + 8 à 10 milliards c'est
considérable on peut faire encore
beaucoup mieux
et puis dire et pour terminer là dessus
si que recherche innovation c'est pas
que l'amour c'est l'ensemble de la
filière si l'âme on va bien et que laval
ne se porte pas bien
et ben là mon finir comme laval et
inversement
et inversement donc c'est l'ensemble de
la filière l'amont et l'aval en tant que
migrants je peux vous dire qu'au niveau
des entreprises agroalimentaires celles
ci vont bien quand l'agriculture va bien
et inversement
voilà donc fait confiance laissez-nous
faire des recherche innovation fait tout
confiant vous pourrez contrôler mais de
la liberté d'entreprendre et l on l'a
enfin vrai moteur de croissance
merci pour ce témoignage